enter your story
one time
a few years ago
I met a guy
at a bar
I was from Ghana
I dated him for two
before I moved in with
[Music]
and he went back to his home country of
Africa
about three months later I flew out
there to go see him
I spent
do we stand
and ki proposed and I said No
I said no because there was no guarantee
that he would come back to America and
anyone
in Ghana so
after we back home to my little small
town in the middle of nowhere in
buck-toothed Missouri and
he is married to someone else and had to
say
so now I'm here on vacation
in San Diego
I guess I'm gonna be single tone 35 in a
story basically the point is take the
opportunity when you can okay so there
was a little ogre she was like four
years old she was all on her own okay
and her family's gone and the problem is
she can only eat little boys so she like
sets traps for them in the forest okay
and one day she catches one and brings
him back to her home and she leaves a
minute at her kitchen so she can get
things ready right but she's not hungry
yet because she just had food so she's
gotta wait a couple days and so they
start talking okay and he's like the
whole time he's like really innocent and
naive and like trying to just be
friendly and you know when it comes time
for her that like prepare the meal she
can't bring herself to do it
all right and eventually one day she
like just needs to get him out of the
house because she can't take his
presents anymore and so she like leaves
the cage open but he doesn't go away so
she's stuck with them
and he just really wants to be her
friend and you know it sets to become a
problem because she has to eat since
she's getting really weak but with his
help she overcomes this need and he
leaves amicably and later in life they
come back together and they have lots of
little children and the boys and girls
and some of the girls have the okra
teeth and it's just a really pleasant
wasn't story of a of a person helping
another person overcome something about
themselves
[Music]
well one time when I was a kid I have
two older siblings and my brothers four
years older and my sister is two years
older than me and I was probably four or
five when we got this big awning thing
the thing that you put on on your porch
and it goes out and in so it came in
this big cardboard tube and we were
playing with it and then we also had a
tree house in our tree house we had this
big window and so we took the cardboard
tube and we placed it on the window and
so here's the tree house and then the
tube came down and we used it as a slide
and so I was in the tree house and my
brother was at the bottom and my sister
between us she was going down the slide
and my brother he accidentally picked up
the bottom of it and so this big
cardboard tube that she was inside it
got picked up and it fell down and
Cristina my sister probably felt like 15
feet and she bit through her tongue and
so we had to like take her to the
hospital I think but from then on we
just knew not to play on slides because
you know I have few years before that
she had actually chipped her tooth on
slide on a slide that we were playing
with so I guess she and slides don't
really mix is the moral of the story
I came from Florida to see her she's my
girlfriend okay we've been dating for a
year and we finally decided to each
other wait you guys hear that first time
these our first time meeting each other
this is their last day in San Diego well
hurt my elastic she lives here oh yeah I
love your own Island okay so how'd you
guys meet so it was like you know like
catfish but we actually are people who
said we were a little while ago how does
that work
and you know we're all humans we have
bodily functions and one of those
publishes is passing gas and sometime
for a ton accident it just comes out
right so I was at work I was at the
register and I was bringing up this
adult and this child this child was
probably I'd say probably about like but
level
I'd say he's growing he's a kid he's
growing and he have to be sitting right
behind me at the register and like I
said were humans and we have Bobby
functions at Bart and so sure enough as
I was doing the transaction I farted and
the child was standing right behind me
and it farted in the child's face not
loud enough for the adult to hear it was
like a very light sound kind of like
when you're you know the ketchup bottle
when you're trying to push up that
little little bit of ketchup it comes
out so that's what happened not allowed
enough for the parent to hear but loud
enough for the child to hear and I
noticed it and I haven't and so the kid
kind of looked up at me with disgust
like it's just the scoff like and I kind
of didn't say anything cuz the parent
didn't hear so I like I handed the
parent their bag and said have a good
day and in the child and the parent
I'm hoping that it didn't give that
child pinkeye
this one time I walked into a record
store and then I picked out just a
random album and it ended up being my
favorite artist in the entire world ever
Kid Cudi's God
no and now he's my favorite artist in my
favorite artist last five years my story
today is doing our visit here in San
Diego something that's been really
interesting is all our uber rides is my
first time doing over and so I guess my
stories about stories so all the
different little personalities of the
uber drivers and the music they chose
and what they chose to share with us was
really sweet and entertaining so I
wanted a cat my whole life and my family
was allergic so I never got one and then
I got a cat and he is the greatest thing
ever and I wanted him to have a buddy
for a really long time so I got him a
little kitten friend in January and May
the cutest best friends they snuggle
they play and they are so awesome and
they make my life a lot happen I guess
my last year's goal to go here I went to
have a soupy trial in Arizona it was
like really cool you had to get the
permits it's only like one hour of like
one day of the whole year to get a
permit to go to this place so and I was
actually guy really get the permit to go
and it just became like really hard once
I got the permit my girlfriend were
supposed to come with me and then
unfortunately she had an issue that she
couldn't come and then all of a sudden
she could come and then all of a sudden
she had death in the family so she
couldn't come and of course like halfway
going there my car breaks down and it
overheats and like my head gasket blows
so it's like this huge thing never had a
problem with my car for 17 years and all
of a sudden now I have a problem and I'm
in the middle of the desert nowhere then
I was able to come up with the solutions
to find someone to tow it find someone
repair it
find someone to come the secondary
repairs to get a rental car that felt
through I had to find another rental car
finally I got to where I needed to get
to none of it worked out the way I
expected to work out I was expecting to
be there with my girlfriend get there
really early in the morning spend all
day and all this stuff and I got there
really late in the afternoon all by
myself had to hike through the through
the desert about 10 miles through the
heat but I was able to get there spent
two days there I was only expecting to
spend one so it worked out that I
actually got to see more of it than I
was expecting to see so like I was like
all stressed about getting there but
like what I actually got there it was
like this amazing wonderful thing Zilla
reading it turned out to be really
really an amazing experience and that's
my story
this morning I was really worried about
getting my poster here on time
from my advisor was bringing it and he
text me he's like well good news is we
have two copies of your poster which
means he doesn't have his poster an hour
before his presentation one time the
first time we ever went jet skiing
together we were in Florida and we had
just rented these jet skis and we had to
go through a channel to get out to the
ocean and as we made it through the
channel there was a huge hailstorm that
crashed out right on it said right as we
got into the ocean so we had no choice
but to turn around and it followed us
all the way back in through the channel
all the way back into the channel we got
back after the most near-death
experience 20 minutes into this and they
refused to give us a refund my cell
homeless last night I almost asking for
food they have any food so I came out 20
bucks and I told to to go to the street
so it's just like a
store open 24 hours late go go buy
yourself something right there it was
really grateful
like appreciated he was telling me like
all I've been starving for three days
for now then just came out of nowhere
and give me this
I always school I know the struggle he
appreciated me give me a hug even though
he smells but I was fine and yeah well
some I like they will feel good you know
because one is like I don't know I
shouldn't be about money you know it
should be like about like you sure yes
rich of life
that's what I just received this I don't
know half doctor you did I like a
materialist just I'm gonna be anything
just like the person you were and that's
not that's what I got when I was with
the homeless person
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Mariah and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the New Year's to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general
don't need a lot thank you